You know if you listen to a complex
piece of music or at least this is my
experience with complex music is
sometimes the first time I hear it.
I don't really like it and I don't I
don't.
I think I also don't understand it.
I actually can't hear it.
You know maybe a musical genius could
hear the whole thing instantly you know
say Franz Liszt.
They say he could sight read anything on
the piano first try.
So you know some people are so
intelligent musically that it's
incomprehensible and I'm sure they hear
things just fine the first time they
hear them but then what happens for me
is that if I listen to it a couple more
times there are pieces chunks of it that
start to fall into place that I can
follow.
And you know I can see the beauty sort
of shining through those and then
eventually the whole thing.
Leaks together and then I can listen to
it especially if it's a complete black
piece of music.
Many many many times.
And the more complex and probably the
better.
The piece of music the more I can listen
to it but if I listen to it enough at
some point then I've had enough of it
and it's all very strange phenomena.
Because one of the things you might ask
yourself is What exactly are you
learning while you're doing that.
You're you know it seems like you want
the music it's something like you want
the music to be.
Just exactly the right amount of
predictable and unpredictable and if
it's too unpredictable then you can't
understand it and if it's too
predictable it's boring and so it's just
like a conversation not way.
It's actually just like life as well.
Because you want things to be
predictable and stable.
And you want things to be unpredictable
and interesting.
And the degree to which you want each of
those is going to depend on the time and
the context.
And also on your own intelligence and
temperament.
So.
Now I'm going to.
Tell you a bunch of stories and give you
a bunch of a number of pieces of
information and.
Hopefully they'll click together.
Now I think the reason that this
information is always being transmitted
in story in image form is because it's
very very difficult to transform it into
articulated into fully articulated
explanation.
It isn't really how it works.
No we're not really accustomed to
thinking about the idea that there are
certain forms of information that.
And that that are valid forms of
information that can't be transmitted
verbally.
Of course if you think about it we all
understand this deeply because while I
can give you a bunch of examples the
first example is that when you speak not
only do you speak in words and phrases
in sentences and paragraphs but you also
speak melodically and in fact part of
the reason that you can understand
melodies and that they make sense to you
is that what artists have done is
separated the melodic element of speech
from the semantic element and then
played with the melodic element and the
melodic element tends to carry a lot of
emotion and intent and soul.
If you're listening to someone speak you
can tell when they're being ironic you
know because they raised an eyebrow and
their voice changes slightly even though
they might be using in fact they are
using exactly the same words and in fact
someone who's very good at being witty
or ironic will set the situation up so
that you can barely tell that they're
joking.
And the better they are at that the.
Time of year that they give you that you
can still catch onto the funny or the
situation is so.
So we know that the information can be
transmitted through non-verbal channels
if it even happens during speech.
And then of course we understand that
music.
Presents to us an intimation of meaning
that's very difficult to fully grasp.
And music for me has always been a
ineffable phenomenon in some sense
because.
It carries the intimation of meaning in
a manner that can't be rationally
dismissed or that people are interested
in rationally dismissing.
So even punk rock nihilists listen to
punk rock nihilistic music and they know
they find that meaningful even though
they don't believe in meaning.
And you know in some sense they're
victims of their own rationality because
they do believe in meaning or they
wouldn't be listening to the music but
they can't understand how they could
possibly believe in it so their rational
mind has dispensed with the idea.
And sometimes that's people dispense
with the idea of meaning for lots of
reasons partly because of because it's
inevitable in some sense with sufficient
rationality but also because because
it's always useful to look.
For the.
Underbelly of things because it also
justifies not bearing any responsibility
for your life and not fairly.
What that can be a very desirable side
effect of a particular ideological
irrational belief.
And then there's dance of course and
dance is even more ineffable.
The music although it's often paired
with music you know when it's and it it
grips people if you see a remarkable
dance performance.
Well part of it is that you're sort of
thrilled and excited about seeing just
exactly what the human form can do.
Because perhaps partly because you're
human and when you see someone extending
a certain ability far beyond the norm
then it expands your sense of what a
human being is capable of.
So there so there's that there's just
the pure steel element and then there's
the novelty element because often if you
watch a particularly good dancer there's
things they do that you haven't seen
before that you didn't know anyone could
do and that's pretty fun and then often
the dances.
Is joined with the music and the body is
expressing what the music means and even
though you can't tell what the music
means you can tell that that dance is
expressing.
And see I think what happens there is
that music represents the patterns of
being.
It's actually because people think of
music as a Non-representational art but
I think that's wrong.
I think it might be the most
representational art is that being is
made up of layers of patterned layers of
patterns constantly interaction
interacting and hopefully in a
relatively harmonious way and music.
Music demonstrates that mimics that in
some sense abstractly and then the dance
is an abstract representation like
people adapt to the patterns of being
and the dancer adapts to the pattern of
music and so it's symbolic it's an
embodied display of the place of the
person in the cosmos.
And you can you can also make that case
when you see people dancing in pairs
because you can dance alone or you can
dance in pairs and that's basically
standard human adaptation.
And music is interesting too because one
of the things that you'll notice is that
there's always music in a movie almost
always there's the movie that doesn't
have it's quite marked.
When it's absent you know the movie
feels a lot more cold and clinical
although it can work.
But we accept the idea that music can be
used to fill in the missing context in a
movie without even ever questioning it.
Right.
Like it's very strange if you think
about it that you go to a movie that is
doing at least at least part of its
function is to portray reality in a
realistic way.
But there's a soundtrack playing in the
background all the time and you don't
know it.
It's so useful and so appropriate that
you don't notice how strange it is that
that's OK.